[Applaudissements]
je n'ai jamais été seule je suis né à 2
j'ai une soeur jumelle
elle s'appelle lui si elle est brillante
et c'est probablement la personne qui me
fait le plus rire au monde
si je vous dis ça c'est que naître à
deux c'est pas anodin naître à 2 c se
construira deux en binôme
c'est être amené à être toujours en
relativité par rapport à quelqu'un donc
toujours à se comparer moi c'est ce qui
m'a amené à me poser pas mal de
questions sur notre système éducatif
je suis un pur produit de l'éducation
nationale emballé au lycée henri iv
packagée dans une grande école celle ci
j'ai suivi la route
l'autoroute même parfois sans trop me
poser de questions ces pratiques en une
autoroute ont souvent en pilote
automatique
alors notre système éducatif il est
parfait pour les gens comme moi pour ces
types de talent là des personnes
structuré qui peuvent voir la vie en
trois parties trois sous parties qui
savent s'adapter pour tous les autres
ceux qui comme ma soeur veulent pas
tellement s'adapter ceux qui sont hors
cadre l'école est souvent perçue comme
une lutte une lutte dont il faut sortir
victorieux c'est à dire avec le bac ou
un diplôme
ce petit bout de papier qui va nous
permettre enfin de commencer sa vie pour
toutes ces personnes en fait c'est une
fois seulement sorti du système qu'ils
se rendent compte qu'ils sont bons à
quelque chose qu'ils ont des talents
alors je vous rassure ma soeur va très
bien elle a très bien réussi mais moi
pendant toutes ces années je me suis dit
qu'il y avait un problème il ya un
problème de gâchis de talents
pourquoi est-ce que le talent de ma
soeur anne mais a dû mettre tant de
temps avant de s'exprimer
pourquoi elle a mis vingt ans avant de
pouvoir exceller et pourquoi mon talent
uniquement été reconnu à l'école
parce qu'un talent en fait c'est pas
seulement être virtuose au piano on a
une vision hyper restreinte du talent du
coup on a l'impression qu'on en a pas un
talent au sens propre du terme
c'est quelque chose que l'on fait
naturellement sans effort ça peut être
avoir une capacité d'écouté incroyable
ça peut être être super organisé ou
savoir convaincre n'importe qui en 22
minutes
on a tous des talents simplement n'en
est pas conscient
d'abord parce que on le fait justement
sans effort
ensuite parce que généralement on les a
pas tellement valorisé à l'école et
encore plus probablement vous ne les
utilisez pas dans vos métiers
alors pourquoi c'est important de savoir
son talent ok petit sondage rapide
je vous vois qui ici c'est déjà dit au
moins une fois je suis nul
soyez honnête hockey qui s'est déjà dit
je ne suis pas légitime dans ce que je
fais ok et je n'y arriverai pas ok les
trois à la fois
ouais ok cela vous viendrez me voir à la
fin ça va bien se passer
on a une cellule psychologique non
sérieusement on se dit tous ça tout le
temps je me dis ça à peu près tous les
jours c'est justement pour ça que c'est
super important de se demander en quoi
on est bon quelles sont nos talents à
quel moment dans sa vie on exprime
pleinement pleinement nos potentiels
alors moi j'ai eu de la chance parce que
j'ai été amené à me poser quelques unes
de ces questions assez rapidement en
fait en arrivant dans ce bel
établissement
il s'est passé deux choses la première
c'est que j'ai perdu mon talent en fait
je venais d'une classe préparatoire
littéraire donc je suis passé de
questions métaphysiques à la gestion
financière
le choc a été un petit peu rude et du
coup j'étais plus si forte que ça à
l'école
alors ça m'a amené à la deuxième chose
me poser la question abyssale
pourquoi pourquoi j'ai étudié ce que
j'étudiais alors on me parlait de
maximisation des profits d'une
entreprise mais j'avais un peu du mal à
croire que c'était la seule finalité de
tout mais les matières et donc pendant
cette première année je me suis posé
plusieurs fois la question de partir de
fuir et puis bon je me suis dit que
j'avais quand même pas mal travaillé
pour en arriver là
ça valait peut-être le coup de creuser
cinq minutes alors je suis parti mais la
découverte de mon école et c'est là que
j'ai découvert cette alliance de deux
mots improbables entrepreneuriat social
cessé de mots qu'ils allaient me
passionner pour les 8 années à venir
c'est là que j'ai compris que prendre le
large
en fait c'est parfois faire l'effort de
rester mais bon à l'époque j'avais pas
encore intégré cette leçon pour moi
prendre le large
c'était uniquement partir loin partir
ailleurs
alors c'est ce que j'ai fait je suis
parti en voyage autour du monde pendant
neuf mois c'était génial
et puis je suis rentré en france et là
j'étais paumé - l'époque je voulais
repartir je voulais partir vivre à
l'étranger de nouveaux ailleurs fuir
encore mais en fait le vrai voyage
il a commencé ici enfin pas à cergy mai
à paris pas très loin il a commencé par
une rencontre celle de trois personnes
incroyables à refaire le monde autour
d'une mauvaise bouteille de vin rouge
ils m'ont proposé de rejoindre leur
voyage celui d'une aventure
entrepreneuriale qui en fait allait me
permettre d'agir pour le problème qui me
touche est vraiment celui du gâchis de
talents
alors il ya trois ans avec ses associés
et l'aide de beaucoup d'autres personnes
on a monté ticket de feurs challenge ti
cats for change
le point de départ c'est que chacun de
nous a des talents ça j'espère que c'est
bon je vous ai convaincus maintenant la
vraie question
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait de ses
talents comment est-ce qu'on permet à
chaque personne d'utiliser ses talents
pour avoir un impact positif sur la
société
comment on fait rencontrer chaque
problème du monde avec un de ses talents
pour le résoudre
parce qu'en fait il existe des milliers
de personnes en france qui ont envie
d'agir mais elles savent pas par où
commencer
on a même fait une étude avec un cabinet
spécialisé au niveau national on a
découvert que sur 100 français il y en a
74 qui déclare vouloir agir pour
résoudre un enjeu de société mais qui ne
le font pas ça c'est du gâchis de
talents
alors comment on fait pour aider tous
ses talents à agir à passer à l'action
nous on développe des programmes de
formation et de sensibilisation à
l'entrepreneuriat
après un incubateur de start up social
un cours en ligne gratuit ouvert à tous
des ateliers des conférences
en trois ans on a touché plus de
cinquante trois mille personnes
on a permis à plus de 400 projets
d'émerger et on a accompagné dans la
durée 89 start up social dont certaines
sont ici ou plutôt on a accompagné 89
talent parce que oui on les aide à
développer leurs projets on les aide du
point de vue juridique financier on leur
fait rencontrer les bons mentor les bons
experts on les aide surtout ça mais en
fait là où c'est vraiment unique
c'est qu'on les aide à activer leur
talent et c'est là qu'ils deviennent
vraiment entreprenants parce qu'en fait
entrepreneur c'est éphémère c'est un
statut c'est un métier être entreprenant
c'est durable c'est une posture
en fait c'est être capable dans
n'importe quelle situation
que ce soit dans sa vie personnelle ou
dans sa vie professionnelle d'aborder
chaque problème qui se pose à nous en se
demandant est ce qu'il y aura pas une
solution pour le résoudre
alors ça tombe bien parce qu'on va en
avoir pas mal des problèmes à résoudre
ces prochaines années
des problèmes locaux des problèmes
globaux
urgent important vous les connaissez
mais j'ai trois très bonnes nouvelles la
première c'est qu'il ya déjà des gens
qui nous montre la voie qui agissent qui
nous montrent que c'est possible je vous
ai parlé de 89 d'entre eux mais il y en
a des milliers d'autres en france et des
millions dans le monde
la deuxième c'est que chacun de nous est
porteur de solutions
chacun de nous a un ou plusieurs talents
qui lui permettent d'aborder chaque
problème du monde avec un angle unique
particuliers et enfin la troisième c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ses talents ils ont un
impact potentiel démultipliée grâce aux
nouvelles technologies grâce à ces
ordinateurs surpuissants contre à mal
tous dans nos poches
on peut faire des choses extraordinaires
de notre salon on est des super héros
potentiels
alors oui prenez le large prenait le
large mais faites le de manière
entreprenante
partez loin s'il le faut mais partait en
vous demandant pourquoi vous partez et
surtout partez à la découverte de vos
même partez à la découverte de vos
talents
faites l'exercice demain où cette
semaine essayer vraiment de voir des
situations encore une fois de ma vie
personnelle ou professionnelle dans
lesquels vous vous sentez pleinement
vous-même pleinement unique
ces moments vous sentez que vous
exploitez votre potentiel vous êtes bons
noté le garder longtemps vote dans le
coin de votre tête ou mieux encore dit
le formuler le alors c'est super
flippant
je sais du coup je vais vous montrer
je le faire
moi mon talent c'est ma capacité à
transmettre mon énergie à transmettre ce
que je porte c'est fait
maintenant c'est à vous alors à vos
talents prêts partez
[Applaudissements]